the brilliant brilliant Camp of Izzy and
his coach who's absolutely one of the
best to do it they were smart enough to
go if we can pull out and get him to get
comfortable start throwing not just one
shots one shots we can't really counter
it's tough to land a big shot but we can
get him to throw combinations against
the fence give them Close Quarters so
then we can exchange and land one we can
get them out here under five rounds
that's what they did the old rope-a-dope
and you know you saw the boys me and Sam
tripley were rocking the engaged shirt
it's so funny because Izzy has this
collab with Muhammad Ali he pulls the
fight off doing something very similar
that Muhammad Ali did the rope-a-dope
let's lure him in where he gets
comfortable and he's throwing those
combinations and when he's throwing
those combos hands are down and we can
come over to up and land it's insane
that was the game plan but they pulled
it off they pulled it off you'll never
see them fight again